[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today at that
first one George this is this is very
you thank you I don't know if that's a
compliment but I'll take it the first
one we say is crypto is a terrible way
to invest and spend your money we say it
in all the crypto I'm gonna say dudes
it's not a lot I just don't feel like a
lot of the women't ran into a lot of
women a lot of women don't get M because
the guys do the guys are like women use
something called logic a lot or his guys
are like it's like a flex it's like come
on man yeah crypto now you know women
have girl math and so they're not
innocent true that's true justify some
spining crypto from the very beginning I
was just like scratching my head about
crypto and I thought well maybe I'm not
dumb enough to understand and the more I
looked into it the stupider it got and
now on the other side of it we kind of
all know it was a farce just not good
and the reason is I'll give you a real
reason crypto is not based in anything
it's just based on hype when you even
buy a single share of a company you're
hoping that the company produces more
profit and revenue whereas crypto is
just I made a coin this is the coolest
hottest coin come get my coin and so
it's very multi-level marketing Vibes
and so I always joke that crypto is just
Mary Kay for young men for that reason
which no offense to the Mary Kay ladies
okay there are some some yeah Die Hard
Mary Kay they're out there so that's
that the second thing people just yeah
they don't care for us on uh you
shouldn't use credit cards ooh we talk
about this a lot that increasingly is
controversial yeah and people you know
it's because the points and the airline
miles what they get from it they claim
is is worth it um but when you sit in
our seat we talk to so many people where
credit cards are not a blessing it's not
a thing that has helped people it's
actually gotten people into a lot of
trouble and they end up being in a
financial position where the credit card
company is winning and they're not
winning and we want you to win and then
you can go through all the you know the
amount of stuff that doesn't work when
it comes to the points in the airline
miles playing the game you can go
through the moral side door of they get
to you get these points and you get this
this cash back and you get the airline
miles and everything because other
people are not paying off their cards
Banks make their money off of interest
and so they're making all this money off
of people that are struggling and then
you know reaping the benefits so it's
like it's just a gross it's a gross
thing all the way around to me and I'm
like if you have a debit card like just
pay for everything in the present and
then go pay for your Southwest flight
like just save up bu and save up it's so
much more freeing and statistically what
you save by not paying on a credit card
in turn could actually help you have
hundreds of dollars throughout the year
to spend on an airline ticket that you
pay for and I'm going to call out all
the Ramy fans who what they're they're
what we call Ish where they go I did
everything but I still have my credit
card I pay it off every month Rachel so
I'm fine and I've convinced a whole
bunch of people to try a 30-day credit
card challenge where they just I saw
this put it in a block of ice and we're
starting to get the results and there
was an interesting someone just said
this I thought it was interesting they
said a few months ago I decided to ditch
the Apple card and just use the money I
have I just wanted to try it out they
said I've definitely seen a noticeable
reduction in my spending and I've
created more margin in my budget for
savings and they said it's just the
little things there's something about
checking my balance inst seeing it
instantly go down after a purchase that
really worked to optimize my spending I
go out to lunch less I buy less extra
stuff at the grocery store store you
just make more intentional decisions and
so it's your money and even if that's
you you're the perfect spender as I call
them you're still spending more than you
would have it's true all right next uh
next save $1,000 emergency funds people
are like inflation 2023 this is the same
advice you all gave in 1993 you know
shouldn't it change with expenses being
higher and things being more expensive
that's a big one and funny enough when
Dave came up with this principle baby
step one 30 years ago $1,000 wasn't
enough back then to get the new HVAC
system and cover the big life
emergencies and so the principle of it
is it's meant to be a starter emergency
fund it's Dave started this because
people were trying to get out of debt
but they'd have these little ankle
biters that would knock them back knock
them back and so it's the goal is to
cover the ankle biters if you have a big
emergency number one we want you to have
good insurance in place to cover some of
that the health stuff and number two you
pause the baby steps you save up fast
sell stuff whatever you need to do to
cover the EXP most of these emergencies
are not the money's due today or else
the house is getting foreclosed on right
that's right that's right yeah so yeah
the, it's meant to be a quick step two
30 days or less because we want you to
get traction and so much of personal
finance is is behavior change and for
some people they can't even cover a $400
emergency in cash yeah four out of 10
people have zero in savings that's right
is what we found so even $1,000 may feel
like an uphill battle but when you do it
quickly and you have it and then you can
move on to paying off debt that that's
what it's there for it's for the quick
win it's for the ankle biters stuff that
comes up in order to pay off the debt
which leads us to number four George pay
off your debt smallest amount to largest
amount regardless of interest rates this
where the math nerds show up all the
math nerds are like why in the heck
would you not pay off the 25% credit
card versus you'll save $300 in interest
Rachel if you pay off the highest
interest first that's so dumb and I'm
like or you could have paid zero in
interest if you never went into debt so
why are we having this theoretical
discussion yeah so silly but the reason
we do it again is what I was saying
earlier is is these quick wins and when
you pay off that smallest debt even if
it's a $400 credit card bill that's been
just like laying around right you pay it
off you start to actually win and you
start to feel like oh my gosh I can do
this and so that's it's a powerful
motivator yeah getting out of debt is
way more about Hope and momentum and
progress than it is about mathematical
interest and we've done the math the
amount is negligible about how much
you're really going to save by doing the
Avalanche and I just have not seen
people come and drove saying Rachel I
did the Deb aval Avan and that's why we
got out of debt it's likely you'll stay
in debt longer or give up or fall off
the wagon if you don't see that progress
fast all right last but not least uh if
crypto was yours George I feel like this
is
mine married couples to combine
accounts you would think that I just
told you you got three heads Rachel
telling us to do that yeah I mean like I
don't even I mean it like people get so
mad my last two where's anger coming on
Instagram George my my the last two
reals I've done about this over like 3
million views each and all in the
comments they're like this woman has
says a woman says a woman woman that's
what a lot of them say and I'm like I'm
sorry can I go out on lamb and say those
guys are single and I'm like yes just
going to say that out loud oh man people
get pissed about this well they see
joint bank accounts as she's going to
take you to the cleaners that's the very
toxic mentality that some guys out there
have and I always have the as trick you
guys and and on the show we do this and
we've actually had callers that call in
with situations and we tell them the
opposite of this advice if there's an
abuse situation if there's an addiction
that's not being addressed like if there
are things that you have to do to keep
yourself safe absolutely like absolutely
I am not against that but if you're just
a married couple out there both bringing
in an income but she money and her money
she pays these bills I pay these you go
on vacation they get the hotel you get
the I mean your roommates you are acting
like your roommates and it's never just
about the money it's never just about
the account it's the idea that you
actually don't see yourself fully as a
team and don't fully trust your spouse
and if that is you then you need to ask
like okay why is that because there's
probably going to be other issues going
on that are going to come up in other
parts of your marriage so we can go on
and on about this but I'm telling you
people that win with money when you're
married you see yourself as a team you
win faster and I think you and you're
and your marriage becomes better so many
people have stood on the stage George to
scream their debt free and they talk
about how much how unified they are well
it's transparency accountability
communication you know all the Hallmarks
of a great marriage be married be be a
team so anyways there there you go that
is our most hated Financial advice and
we you're only fueling us this is the
Ramsey Show